I never expected having a child to change
my identity in so many different ways.
You see, I love working.
I really love working, and I love being a
developer, I love being an engineering manager.
I love solving hard problems every day.
And I've always worn a lot of hats.
I work at GitHub as the engineering manager
as well for another team that is working on
a secret product, re-imagining fun and collaboration
in code.
I'm also a Mozilla tech speaker, on the word
of Ruby Together, and I run a podcast about
parent-driven development.
I have stickers for all of these things.
If you want to chat about any of them, please
come and find me.
I've been a community organiser, a mentor,
a developer, an organiser, a COO, and then,
all of a sudden, I was a mom.
So this is Devon.
He was important in April 2015.
This talk is going to have a lot of pictures
of him.
Devon's a full-blown toddler now and joined
by his sister, Layla who is just over a year.
Today, I want to talk about the challenges
people who are parents and developers face,
as well as what some solutions are, and how
these solutions can help a company and an
entire team.
So, when Devon was about five months old,
I felt like I was losing my mind.
I had been back at work full-time for a while
- if you want to hear a separate rant, talk
to me about maternity leave in the States
- and after a particularly bad week of very
little sleep at night, and having a really
challenging workweek, I just really wasn't
sure if I could do it.
How was I going to keep learning all the things
I needed to be learning while being a great
mom, employee, and adequate partner?
How did did others do it?
Was I being unrealistic?
Was I being lazy.
Could I even be a good mom and a developer
or was this industry just truly not for me?
If I've being really honest, there's been
many times in the past four years where even
though I loved tech and I loved code, I thought
about how nice it would be just to go and
do a job that I could do on autopilot.
I seriously thought about leaving the industry.
You see these cute pictures of parents orchids
on Facebook or Instagram, but it's not always
like that, and, for me, in the early days,
it definitely usually wasn't like that.
It has hard, tiring, frustrating.
It was also amazing, and all-encompassing.
It was really, really lonely.
Based on what I was experiencing, I created
a survey to ask parents a few questions about
this issue, and what I found out from reading
hundreds of surveys, is there are some real
trends and common issues.
In an industry, the values - in a industry
that voles open-source contributions, parents
are struggling.
So let me take a second to describe a typical
day from a few months ago.
So Devon wakes up around seven, Layla already
around 730.
A lot of parents say it's closer to 5.30 or
six.
I would nurse Layla while Devon has a glass
of milk and by 8.15, we really need to get
moving, brush teeth, make car breakfasts - you
can feel free to judge.
We're not morning people, car breakfast is
what works very well for us.
And at 8.45 or nanny comes which is already
a huge privilege.
By nine I drop Devon off at preschool.
By 9.25 I was home pumping breast milk while
eat breakfast and starting to check emails.
I would jump into the work day, do that punctuated
by a few more breast-milk pumping breaks until
about 5.15.
Then I race out the door, grab Layla, put
her in the car, from 6.15 to 7.15, we do dinner
for the kids, sometimes try to cook our dinner,
Bath time, bed tile, et cetera.
From .45 until around nine, we finish cooking,
we eat dinner, clean up, prep food in bottles
for the next day, jot down childcare notes,
talk about pertinent household stuff we need
to, usually relax for like 30 minutes, and
then we head to bed.
We have it pretty good, even with two.
Now, fortunately, this was a day from a couple
of months ago.
I got a lot more time back in my day as I
weaned my daughter and didn't need to pump
breast milk.
Dropping the number of times that I had to
pump in a day felt amazing.
I had more time to concentrate and didn't
have to go through this huge context-switch
every two hours.
And I mention this tangent because pumping
breast milk was mentioned in over half of
surveys for mothers and their answer is about
company provision or issues they faced.
Now, the only time in that whole day that
I would have to do any code for myself would
be those last 30 minutes that I have to relax,
and even if I gave up that little bit of self-care
time, my brain is so tired by then, I wouldn't
get anywhere fast.
And if you think about this in terms of code
challenges that often need to be completed
outside of your work day for new jobs, parents
may have to spend the whole weekend just working
on a couple of code challenges.
It also means depending on our partner or
spouse to do the childcare and not seeing
your kids.
This might not seem like a big deal, but when
you're already working full-time, it really
is.
This is even more challenging if you're a
single parent.
If you're a accessible parent, then you're
likely paying for weekend childcare to get
these code challenges done.
Another issue mentioned was being able to
stay sharp.
Developers live on coffee and solve really
hard problems.
If you are a nursing mom, you're probably
getting significantly less sleep, and you
can't rely on those cups of coffee to keep
you going.
A recent study from baby care found that over
40 per cent of parents with babies aged zero
to six months only get one to three uninterrupted
hours of sleep per night.
Parents lose a total of 44 days of sleep in
their child's first year, and a newer study
found that parents are sleep-deprived for
six years after they have a kid, and I'm like
really selling this parenting thing right
now!
It's hard to keep a clear mind and solve hard
problems when you're not getting uninterrupted
sleep, and you don't get the weekend to catch
up or recharge.
A parent wrote, "Sometimes, the last thing
I want to do or even have time to do when
I get home is code or learn new code.
Gone are the days of no responsibility and
doing whatever I like when I get home.
Finding a couple of hours to work on a personal
project or pick up something new is hard,
especially when trying to help out my other
half who is also tired."
When I asked if having children helped or
hurt their career, only a small portion of
fathers said it hurt their career.
They felt it either helped or had a future
impact.
About 60 per cent of women said that having
children hurt their career, but even more
than that, said it didn't hurt their career,
but it changed it.
Many women said it slowed their career, affecting
the overall trajectory and growth potential.
Now, I don't know about you, but that description
certainly sounds like hurt ing mothers clearest
to me.
So here's the total breakdown of parents based
on if they felt that having a child helped,
hurt, or had no impact, or helped and hurt
their career.
Here are those same traces based on mom answers
and bad answers.
As you can see, when everyone is together,
the portions are equal.
As you break it down, it tells a much different
story.
This data is backed up by additional research.
This 2018 study on children and gender and
equality in Denmark shows these results based
on gender and earnings in Denmark, which I
know at least for most Americans consider
closer to the gold standard in terms of supporting
parents.
So while there are lots of challenges that
parents face, there are also lots of solutions.
Looking at these surveys, they're identifiable
solutions that companies can put in place,
solutions that colleagues with or without
children can employ, and things that parents
out there can also work on.
These solutions can actually benefit an entire
team.
The company- based ones: allow working from
home or unconventional working options.
Even when a parent is ready to come back to
work, offering different options can make
huge difference in their happiness level.
For women who are pumping, being able to work
from home makes an enormous difference.
When I worked from home, I could pump in 22
minutes because I had everything set up, and
ready to go, but any time that I went into
an office, it took me 32 to 34 minutes each
time, because I had to set up, clean up, and
the travel time to get to the room, hope nobody's
in the room, et cetera.
Hopefully, this isn't as much of an issue
in Europe or outside of the States but I wanted
to mention it again, because over half of
surveys from women suggested that issues are
difficulties around pumping pup if you have
women at your company that are pumping in
their bathroom, your company needs to seriously
consider how they prioritise mothers in the
workforce.
Allowing working from home takes the stress
of a commute out of the equation, and allows
parents a little more flexibility and time
in their day.
Another option is to offer a part-time transition
back to work, so surveys show that people
took this in different ways, some working
less hours, some working less days, but a
gradual transition back to work for pretty
much as long as the company can allow it makes
an enormous difference in a parent's lifestyle.
Second, companies can take a much more proactive
role in creating support systems.
So a really simple example of this might be
a parenting Slack channel where parents can
share experiences, issues, and pictures of
their kids.
And a more involved option might be to connect
parents returning to work with those who have
taken parental leave in the past and allow
for it to be a safe space pour both parties
to discuss - for both parties to discuss successes,
issues, and challenges.
Finally, train managers on what to expect
when someone on parental leave comes back
to work.
This is important for moms do dads but moms?
In particular.
Oftentimes, managers in tech may never have
had a mother go on maternity leave for their
team.
They have no idea what challenges she is facing,
what questions might help or hurt her return
back to work transition, and how best to support
her.
Over and over again, I felt my boss was a
big part of my success when I was a new parent.
Third, create realistic expectations returning
to work.
If your company operates out of KPIs, or goal-setting,
recognise these should be revisited when parents
come back to work, and set new goals.
These will likely not be as ambitious as they
did in the past.
If you're a manager, encourage realistic goal-setting,
and, if you're an employee, recognise that
your whole life has changed.
Give yourself a least a quarter or two to
adjust to the new normal.
As your children get older, you will become
what effective goal-setting and realistic
expectations look like for you.
Fourth, if you have children or if you don't
have children or for the majority of your
team is childless, don't make parent stuff
weird.
Talk about nursing, kid things, in whatever
ways feel comfortable.
One of the things that I did when I was back
in the office after my first was create an
emoji for when I was away from my computer
pumping.
This helped me feel open and honest about
what was going on, and it did so in a way
that didn't make my team feel awkward or weird
about it.
After my second, I just stuck my pumping times
right on my calendar so folks didn't schedule
meetings over them.
My previous company, I did a lightning talk
for the engineering team.
I did two while I was pregnant, about what
that was like, and one afterwards about the
science of breast milk and pumping.
My team asked interesting questions and had
much more empathy and understanding for me
afterwards, and my hope is by exposing them
to some of the terminology and experiences
that there will be more understanding and
empathic to women or parents they might work
with in the future.
But, this should not be incumbent on the pregnant
individual to do so.
Managers should have an understanding of these
facts, and also be willing to be the one that
helps their team understand these considerations.
That's realistic expectations and normalising
it.
When creative options, realistic expectations,
support systems, and normalisation of someone's
life choices are incorporated into a team
or company's culture, it is positive, it has
positive benefits for the entire company.
The open acceptance of diversity and intentional
support around the uniqueness of a team-mate's
life creates that sort of in a team.
As they are trained to establish and seek
out things like support systems, or create
realistic expectations, anyone going through
any sort of hardship or life adjustment will
feel supported.
Once you've created these systems and benefits,
it's easier to see how similar accommodations
for others enable teams to thrive.
Support systems could help folks from burning
out, and normalise being open about struggles
and successes makes it more likely that someone
who is burning out will speak up earlier.
Realistic expectations encourage teams to
craft better guidelines around work and promotion
which often help under-represented minorities
succeed.
And creative working options help companies
attract the best talent regardless of where
they reside.
There are also things that we can do as parents.
First, get rid of your parent guilt, which
is so much easier said than done.
So I'm going to tell you a story about Hallowe'en.
My son was a baby, six months old, I made
two Hallowe'en costumes for him, and there's
been so many home-made does actuals since
then.
The picture of both my children, those are
the costumes I frantically finished sewing
eight yours before I had to fly to Malaysia.
Why?
Because, for me, I feel spending this time
after the kids have gone to bed, making their
costumes, of course, that's the reason why
my kids feel like they're my top priority,
right?
No, that's ridiculous statement.
I know it's a ridiculous statement, it's a
ridiculous statement to say, but oftentimes
working parents feel this way.
We feel bad and like we are ordering too much
take-out, or we miss a special activity, but
we also need to realise that working and doing
something that we love is just as important
for us and for our children to see.
A mom said, "I thought I was a bad mother
and developer because I didn't make everything
perfect."
Next schedule, it took me about a year to
do this, but the first time I took a random
day off, where my son was in childcare, my
husband was at work, and I didn't pack my
day filled with catch-up work or household
chores.
I felt so refreshed.
We don't get the weekends to recharge, and
vacations are really not vacations once you
have had a child.
So it's important to not put these days off,
and to make sure that you're taking at least
one every couple of months just to recharge.
Next, optimise the time that you have available.
So as I mentioned before, a lot of surveys
talk about being really aware of the finite
amount of time that parents had do work, so
make sure that you're making the most of these
hours.
Set learning goals, focus and figure out how
to hack your day to create as much time as
possible to add advance whatever goals you're
putting forward for yourself.
Next, we can only make this better if we are
united.
So, it wasn't until I truly felt like I was
teeth ing under the stress that I reached
out to other mum developers.
It wasn't until I reached out that I learned
that lots of people felt the same way that
I did.
I found some excellent communities of moms
in tech, and it's made a huge difference.
Being able to speak with one another, and
share challenges, solutions, and suggestions,
is invaluable.
Just lying having a support group, when you
have a newborn supporting one another as parents
in tech makes us stronger, and better, and
gives us a more united voice.
Next: share that mental load.
So I'm going to talk about moms for a moment,
because mothers are disproportionately affected
by the weight of mental load, although this
happens in most partnerships.
In 2015, the Pugh Research Centre interviewed
1,800 parents in households where they both
work.
They asked who does the work of managing your
children's schedules and activities?
Who takes care of the kids when they're sick?
Marie Kondo's series was a prime example of
women being crushed by responsibilities.
The number of moms who I talked to who told
me they sat on the couch and cried while watching
that show because they felt the same way was
truly incredible.
The New York Times had an article in February
about working mothers in Japan, and it spoke
about how working mothers often work more
than 49 hours a week and typically do close
to 25 hours of housework a week, while their
partners do an average of less than five.
So let's say you have a partner, and let's
say your partner's great which which I have
found is a big assumption, and let's say that
you feel like you've got a good split of work.
You share pick-ups and drop offs, you share
cooking, cleaning, et cetera.
But what about the other stuff?
So, who thinks about what the kids are going
to eat for lunch?
Who schedules doctor's appointments?
Who knows what day school will be loafed?
Who knows what child needs next developmentally
and what is coming after that?
Who buys the birthday presents?
Who reviews homework?
Who plans and packs for family trips?
If you're already splitting this load, then
I applaud you, but for many families, this
isn't the case, so if you're not doing it
already, share that load.
I will rink to a worksheet that can jump start
this conversation.
I put a checklist on the door on who needs
what in order to leave the house in the morning.
I realised that I was taking on the mental
burden of having to make sure that everybody
was ready in the morning, even on the days
that my husband was doing drop-off.
With this list, we can both make sure that
everyone has everything they need without
me needing to be the one that bears that burden.
Finally, if you need to leave your company,
leave your company.
Ultimately, if your company doesn't understand
the lifestyle of you as a parent and doesn't
allow you to be with your children when you
need to be, then, if you can, try to leave.
This advice came up over and over again in
surveys, although admittedly, a lot has been
filled out by senior-level developers.
So I that is disappear self-parent guilt,
self-care days, find a community, share the
mental load and leave if you have to.
For your teams, remember just existing as
a parent on your team makes your teams better.
You're organised, you need to set boundaries,
and you must have some sort of work-life balance.
Being this role model helps everyone, even
if they don't know that you're role-modelling
it.
A little while ago, my team had an os site
that I brought my family to.
In order for me to be available for dinner
and bedtime each evening, my day ended up
at five and we didn't meet until 7.30.
My team brought this about not knowing I had
created that break because I needed to balance
running the offsite with being present for
my family.
When I told them the reason why the break
existed, they saw that not only did that benefit
me and my family but it also benefitted them
by giving them a chance to recharge before
evening activities.
Finally, we're going to talk about what colleagues
can do because colleagues with or without
children have lots of power to make things
better for team-mates and make companies better
in general.
First, ask about lactation rooms.
If you live in a country where moms are still
pumping when they return to work.
I was at a conference once in America, and
I needed a place to pump, and I asked the
front desk person if there was a space other
than the bathroom to do so.
He said, "I think we have a supply closet
somewhere that you can use."
Fortunately, there was a security guard standing
nearby who walked over and said my wife's
going through the same thing, I'm sure we
can do better than a bathroom or supply closet,
and let me look around for you quickly, and
sure enough, they found me an empty office.
Mothers should not be alone in this fight.
If you're company is moving into a new space
or spending money building something out,
suggest they make appropriate accommodations
for mothers returning to work, and if they
don't know what those are, there are plenty
of women who would be happy to talk to them
about it.
Second, just be friendly.
This one is easy, but when folks are coming
back, ask what they're doing.
Coming back to work can be emotional, check
in, show them that you care, and appreciated,
and supported really makes a difference.
Third, make your voice heard.
Someone suggests working late, or schedule
late meetings, see someone criticising a parent
for needing to take time because their child
is sick or has a doctor's appointment, parents
often feel really guilty about taking this
time, or saying, "I have to go, I have to
run to pick up my chilled."
It's helpful for others on the team to speak
up as well and say I know this meeting is
running over, we want to be respectful of
those with the hard stuff.
Or is there any chance we can schedule this
meeting earlier?
I know it doesn't work for everyone's schedule.
Finally, if someone uses a word or concept
that you don't know, Google it.
I like to think that most of us are pretty
good at Google.
We generally like learning new things, so
if you don't know what pumping is, curious
about childcare costs, never heard of a sleep
progression or anything that the parent mentions
on your team, Google it.
There are great resources out there to learn
more.
That summary is lactation rooms, be nice,
speak up, and use Google.
While there are specific things that colleagues
can do to help parents, these actions benefit
everyone and make teams stronger.
These suggestions boil down to increasing
empathy and curiosity, and an interest in
your colleagues and their lives, as well as
a desire to understand one another.
When these factors are incorporated into a
team's DNA, it leads to stronger, more effective
teams that can support and understand one
another more effectively.
You may ask about lactation rooms specifically
to support parents on your team, but you're
also learning to recognise difference situations
where different accommodations are helpful.
You're learning how to support team-mates
by asking questions and figuring out how to
be a better ally on your team, and teams that
are strong in these areas help attract and
remain more diverse talent.
There are some great resources out there.
You can take a look at how your company is
doing, or how companies you're looking at
are doing.
The number-one piece of advice that I got
on surveys was that you will never get this
time with your children back.
So value it, prioritise it, and try to guard
it as much as possible.
There are some days that I still feel like
I'm not sure I can be a successful mom and
in tech, but there are some days that I can
give 100 per cent to both areas, and others
where I feel like I'm letting my family or
my job down.
Oftentimes, though, I find myself calling
on developer or manager strategies for effective
parenting where or vice versa.
I personally think this makes me a better
manager and gives me more experiences and
strategies I can call upon in a variety of
situations.
What I also learned through speaking with
parents and people in the amazing parents
that answered a few questions, is that the
struggle that I face are not unique.
It's important for all of us as a community,
as developers, as colleagues, as peers, and
managers to think about this.
I thought that everything that I was feeling
was just me, but it's everyone.
Everyone has similar concerns, and a lot of
people have the same issues.
So let's think about how we can make it better,
because they're solvable.
Peers with or without children, managers,
directors of engineering, we can make the
lives of the parents in tech better which
will ultimately make our teams and companies
better.
This research is ongoing, so feel free to
check out my Twitter if you want to fill it
out, and, parents, as one person wrote on
their survey, just high-fives.
You're awesome!
Be confident!
Thank you.
[Applause].